la llegada de vallar a la sadayeda marca
las vísperas de un hecho trascendental
para el mundo árabe el regreso de Siria
a una cumbre de la liga regional este
viernes el presidente sirio volverá a
codearse con los líderes del bloque
luego de más de una década de
aislamiento un evento bien recibido por
los demás miembros
doy la bienvenida a nuestra liga nuestro
querido amigo faisalmec ministro de
relaciones exteriores de Siria y espero
que la recuperación de Siria de su
asiento sea un precursor del final de su
conflicto y su regreso a una presencia y
acción vibrante en el mundo árabe
una acogida muy diferente a la de 2011
cuando estalló la guerra civil dentro
del país y Damasco fue marginado
en vista de que el gobierno sirio no
cumplió en su totalidad inmediatamente
la iniciativa de la liga árabe que se
firmó en la reunión a nivel de ministros
de relaciones exteriores el 2 de
noviembre de 2011 anunciamos la
suspensión de la participación de la
delegación Siria en reuniones del
Consejo de la liga á y todas las
agencias asociadas a partir del 16 de
noviembre
se ha convertido en una figura
controvertida para la comunidad
internacional siendo acusado de crímenes
de guerra y jefe de un régimen
involucrado en un conflicto que mató a
350.000 personas llegando a utilizar
hasta bombas químicas contra su propia
población en 2023 para la liga árabe el
retorno de Siria es la posibilidad de
solucionar un problema regional y
separarse a las influencias de las
potencias occidentales para el gobierno
de la Sad una victoria diplomática
sumada al declarado triunfo militar Pese
a que una parte del territorio no ha
quedado en poder del gobierno tras la
guerra civil